it's 9:30 a.m. at a coffee shop in Newry
where folks are once again scratching
their heads about the latest
developments in the brexit saga people
are following the political drama in
London closely the majority of voters
here voted remain and still want to stay
in the EU some are enjoying the
spectacle watching the British
establishments making fools of
themselves
in relation to brags it you know we live
in imperial glories which unfortunately
for them no longer exists
we get much enjoyment out of it but
others like the cafe's owner are angry
Graham Finnegan has invested a lot of
time and money in his new business but
brexit hangs like the sword of Damocles
over his head and has for a long while
yeah I'm absolutely sick to death of
Rexy to be honest I'm sick to death of
the inaptitude and the arrogance of
British government and SEC of David
Cameron resume Forrester Bethune Johnson
particularly for people in the north of
Ireland outside big trucks Thunder by as
new relies on a major transport route
between Dublin and Belfast what will
become of the free trade of goods will
border checks be reintroduced there are
many questions but no answers
yet some in the cafe support brexit so
we have an election that say I'll okay
about it like we're leaving and it's
sort of prolonged and it's one excuse
after the other and wouldn't say I'm
Boris Johnson's biggest fan but he seems
to be rocking a lot of boats and they
say he's lazy he's getting stuff done
these young bankers worry about the drop
in the value of sterling the weakness of
the British Pound is also a problem for
Graham Finnegan he orders coffee beans
from Berlin in Barcelona and pays in
Euros foods like this fresh salmon come
from the Republic of Ireland he's unsure
whether his suppliers will deliver after
brexit but that's not his biggest worry
for Irish people living on the border I
think
the real threat here isn't more
expensive goods in the supermarket but
an actual threat to peace in this
country bronec m'q itas new shares his
concern she experienced the bloody
conflict in Northern Ireland known as
the troubles firsthand in the 1980s
now she's tweeted excerpts of the
diaries she kept as a teenager Rexha is
making people anxious I think especially
older people who lived through the
troubles and her what it's like part of
us maybe wants to feel it can never
really go back to that height of
violence Rona Matassa knee wants to show
us what happened back then she says at
one time Nuri had the highest rate of
bomb attacks during the Troubles more
than 50 people were killed here today
it's hard to believe that civil war
light conditions plagued the city all
the shops are boarded up because you
couldn't very carefully didn't attach
bombs to the front of the shops there
was shootings on a pretty regular basis
army patrols army checkpoints
back at the cafe Graham Finnegan's young
son comes by after school
Graham hopes at his boy and other
children in Newry will grow up in the
united Europe not a deeply divided
United Kingdom